so dave chappelle has a comedy special
on Netflix and it's controversial so
this is a stand-up comedy special it's
an hour long by Dave Chappelle who was
in 2003 to 2005 basically when
Chappelle's Show was on this dude there
was no stopping him and he was hilarious
Chappelle's Show is hilarious and look
at that Chappelle's Show is very
provocative it pushed the lines it would
be seen as controversial if it came out
now in fact I don't think Chappelle's
Show would actually survive in today's
day and age which I find fascinating I
find interesting I feel like he does too
and I feel like that's why he did this
new comedy special sticks and stones the
way he did it he sticks his stones
touches on a lot of stuff he makes jokes
on canceled culture the LGBTQ community
suicide that Michael Jackson documentary
on HBO had more he makes a lot of jokes
a lot of areas a lot of other comics to
be like [ __ ] that I'm not touching it
going into the zones that people
otherwise are like I don't want to touch
on that like the real The Grates they'll
go there they'll make jokes about it and
generally the audience is left with that
that was uncomfortable but I laughed and
that's the point of it the point of it
is to push the lines push the boundaries
like Icarus you fly as close as you can
to the Sun without burning your wings
only thing is in today's social media
day and age is like the sun's expanded
and you can't fly as high as you used to
be able to and that's why I like the
fact that Chappelle's like well I'll
just get stronger wings I love that
about the guy I love that about this
special is it controversial yes is it
offensive that definitely depends on you
because only you can decide whether or
not you're gonna get offended by what he
says I mean when I'm watching it I'm
like oh yeah that'll catch them heat
that will catch some heat too but I
couldn't help but appreciate the fact
that well this guy will do it he'll go
there great comedy great comedians
they're basically an outlet for people
because people have fucked-up thoughts
they have [ __ ] up things that they
think of their fucked-up jokes like in
the early two-thousands dead baby jokes
were a thing but at no point was anyone
like people are really gonna start to
kill babies now because of these jokes
but it's like now everything's
interconnected the safe spaces all we
all need the safe spaces right if you
require a safe space this comedy special
is not the safe space for you which is
probably why you should watch it I mean
let's face it like I hate the cold I
don't really like winter those are not
nice months to me but by the end of
winter I'm like oh it's not so bad
anymore because I kind of got used to
the cold it's like that and a great
comedian when he's being controversial
will leave the audience with like oh I
just have a point that's kind of
thought-provoking right like that's the
thing that's the beauty of it that's how
they can do that a canceled culture
called celebrity hunting season and I
couldn't for the life of me be like you
who's not right about that because this
there's one thing he says about Kevin
Hart he talks about Kevin Hart and how
he basically he quit the Oscars because
the Oscars are like whoa you made those
tweets you need to apologize for those
tweets he talks about how great Kevin
Hart is and he says the line he's like
Kevin Hart is the sweetest guy I've ever
met he is perfect he's in fact so
perfect he is exactly for tweets away
from being perfect and it hits you like
a logic wrecking ball right to your face
you're like yeah taking someone's one
tweet and outrage culturing and cancel
culturing them is minimizing the
entirety of the quality of their
character down to that thing whether
it's like a tweet or a few tweets or a
joke they may have done or said and you
can't help but think like that is a bit
ridiculous like the moral zeitgeist is
constantly changing so a lot of
comedians CHUM's the waters with a lot
of jokes that were fine for the time so
now years later people can go back to
those early things dig up these little
nuggets these little treasures and be
like oh sweet we'll just cancel that
person now the fact being if there was a
line that was crossed back when they did
it would have been the time to tell them
that porn is you can't take Kevin Hart's
tweets oh really anybody's jokes that
they made from what world wars tweets
2009 2011 or something like that and
judged them through the lens of the
collective social morality of 2019 it
just doesn't work Bill Maher addresses
that and says we don't have es PCP
extrasensory politically correct
perception and that's the point of
specials like this is why I like it I
like the fact that Dave Chappelle is
like I'll be the one who does it
it's like saying controversial things
but it does leave you thinking he
doesn't not have a point I feel like
this is a generational gap you know like
I come from a time where comedians were
allowed to say [ __ ] up just like
nothing Chappelle's said in here is more
cut it's not like the most controversial
thing that's ever happened comics and
comedians before him have said more
[ __ ] up [ __ ] things that are more
[ __ ] up than what he said in here only
thing is he made this in this time
but he made it because it's this time so
there's your irony comedians saying
offensive things is a time-honored
tradition like as long as comedy has
been around that has been a fact but
here's the thing it's comedy coming out
of a comedy club or a comedy special
pissed off because a comedian said
offensive things it's like coming out of
a strip club pissed off because my god
they were sexualizing women in there
yeah it's kind of the point of the place
and everyone taking part knows that if
you don't want to take part in that you
just don't
at worst Dave Chappelle is saying
offensive things for the sake of
offending in which case he's apparently
succeeded so good on him and at best
he's using an offensive comedy to make a
few points that are worth talking about
I don't know about you but I saw the
special the crowd was dying of laughter
in a world that's just it's so PC and I
feel like comedy is dying because comedy
is so safe now because entertainers
stand-up comedians even youtubers here's
my nickels worth of free advice for you
people come to you for escapism you are
supposed to present yourself as free of
the [ __ ] given that plagued people on a
daily basis and that's what Dave
Chappelle gave us with this he gave us
someone himself who just he was free of
giving a [ __ ] he said what he said in at
no point are you like oh my god this guy
is totally confined by the social
constructs and social media outrage that
plagues everyone else that really holds
a lot of comics back these days I can't
help but appreciate the fact that he did
that interesting thing is this thing has
like a zero percent on Rotten Tomatoes
is 0% and Rotten Tomatoes with five
reviews at the time of filming this
anyway 5 reviews that's it like Rotten
Tomatoes credited critics are not above
reviewing stand-up comedy specials so I
get the feeling I've no evidence to back
this up but it's just I think a lot of
them actually do like it they like it
but they live in the cesspool known as
Hollywood or Los Angeles whatever you
want to call that armpit and they're
like let's say we like it because we'll
be a pariah [ __ ] that we'll just not
talk about it I have no evidence backing
this up but it's like it's
thought-provoking it's interesting -
[ __ ] it I'll do it like I found out some
months ago I'm accredited Rotten
Tomatoes Critic I didn't ask for it they
just it happens like they were like oh
jeromy's credited now well won't tell
him but he is they take one little line
I say from my reviews and they link to
the YouTube video
that's that and they try to figure out
sometimes when I say good time if you're
drunk he'll accuse her soon his positive
or negative and it's a subject of much
amusement for me but Rotten Tomatoes if
you're watching this the Dave Chappelle
special sticks and stones I'm saying
it's fresh per your metric there so now
it might have one positive review on
Rotten Tomatoes now or they won't maybe
they won't put it up there that's their
prerogative is their website I got my
YouTube channel that's what I concern
myself with but I really mean it I get
that it's gonna be offensive to some
people but life is offensive I don't
actually think he's being mean I don't
think he's like I'm actually I hate
these people no he's being provocative
but through being provocative it
actually lends itself to leaving people
first of all kind of uncomfortable
second of all laughing so now they have
to question whether or not they're
[ __ ] up and I appreciate that but
third of all there's actually a
conversation that could be started with
the things he says in the points he
makes if someone just tweets about it
the whole thing just gets buried under
outrage and they delete the tweet when
it's a comedy special it's out there now
and there's nothing anyone can do about
it I just I appreciate all of that or so
Dave Chappelle sticks and stones have
you seen it what did you think about it
here's the real question these are the
real questions from me did you find it
offensive if you did did you laugh in
this special and if you did laugh and
you found it offensive the things that
were offensive did you also laugh at
those I don't curious they're socially
speaking curious about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and if
you can give this video a like I feel
like this one in particular it might
need it or it won't I don't know but I
feel like it might so if you can hit
that like button I'd appreciate it and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]